buongiorno a tutti grazie di essere qui
uno dei motivi che fin da piccolo mi ha
fatto appassionare alla scienza è stato
la lettura dei fumetti di topolino che
mio padre mi portava quando tornava dal
lavoro in particolare amavo le storie
dei viaggi nel tempo di topolino e pippo
grazie alla macchina del tempo inventata
da zapotec e marlin e che tenevano
nascosta nei sotterranei del museo di
topolinia topolino e pippo entravano in
questa macchina del tempo e venivano
teletrasportati in un luogo lontano
nello spazio tempo potendo così
incontrare che ne so leonardo da vinci
per scoprire i segreti della gioconda
oppure dialogare con napoleone
buonaparte
per capirne la psicologia lo trovo
veramente meraviglioso il fenomeno del
teletrasporto entra poi in gioco in modo
molto importante nella serie tv star
trek dove i protagonisti entravano in
questa camera speciale all'interno
dell'astronave è al comando bimbi up che
possiamo tradurre con teletrasporta mi
venivano dei composti da quella stanza e
ricomposti nel luogo di destinazione
poco dopo assolutamente affascinante tra
l'altro il fatto di trovarmi qui su
questo cerchio rosso un po mi ricorda la
camera del teletrasporto di star trek
c'è però da chiedersi se un corpo umano
e in generale un oggetto macroscopico
può effettivamente essere
teletrasportato per rispondere a questa
domanda possiamo fare un semplice conto
innanzitutto bisogna convertire la
materia in energia
per fare questo possiamo utilizzare la
famosissima equazione di equivalenza
massa energia di albert einstein è
uguale emmeciquadro che più che un
equazione ormai diventata un brand bene
un individuo di 70 kg equivarrebbe a una
energia di mille megaton
che significa più o meno 100 bombe
termonucleari potete immaginare
l'impatto devastante dal punto di vista
ambientale ma c'è di più
se vogliamo ricostruire il corpo nel
punto di arrivo
dobbiamo acquisire tutta l'informazione
possibile su di esso bene il corpo umano
è formato da circa 10 alla 28 atomi è un
numero enorme vuol dire 1 seguito da 28
zeri
a questo punto voi potete scrivere in un
file di testo tutte le informazioni
necessarie per definire un atomo tipico
per esempio l'atomo di carbonio ed
elencate l'uno di elettroni il numero di
protoni il numero di neutroni da cui
essere formato e così via
bene questo file di testo al computer vi
verrebbe delle dimensioni di circa 100
byte
questo significa 10 alla 30 byte di
informazione per il corpo umano si può
stimare che questa informazione equivale
a 10 alla 17 volte cioè 100 milioni di
miliardi di volte
l'informazione contenuta in tutti i
testi scritti finora nella storia
dell'umanità una quantità di
informazione assolutamente impraticabile
vediamo però che succede nel caso in cui
volessimo per esempio evitare quindi il
il traffico cittadino
ve lo potete dimenticare questo e per
dirvi che il teletrasporto per un essere
umano è un corpo macroscopico non si può
fare tuttavia invece di considerare un
oggetto macroscopico possiamo prendere
in considerazione un oggetto molto
piccolo delle dimensioni di un atomo
ovvero del miliardesimo di metro per
darvi un'idea delle dimensioni
se un pallone di calcio fosse grande
quanto il pianeta terra allora un atomo
sarebbe grande quanto una biglia di
vetro del diametro di un centimetro bene
entriamo adesso nel cosiddetto mondo
quantistico e da ora in poi prendiamo la
biglia come il nostro oggetto
quantistico innanzitutto un oggetto
quantistico esibisce il cosiddetto
principio di sovrapposizione o
parallelismo quantistico nel senso che
esso si può trovare simultaneamente in
diverse configurazioni possibili
se per esempio siamo interessati alla
proprietà colore bene questo significa
che la nostra biglia
quantistica può trovarsi
contemporaneamente nel colore giallo blu
rosso arancione
questo è molto strano perché se pensiamo
a una biglia ordinaria sappiamo bene che
questa biglia è o rossa o gialla o blu
dipende da come è stata preparata non
diremo mai che questa biglia e
simultaneamente in tutti questi colori
bene un oggetto quantistico può esserlo
ma ancora più strano è probabile che il
fenomeno dell entanglement che vuol dire
intreccio correlazione e che si viene a
creare quando due oggetti quantistici
chiamiamoli a e b vengono preparati in
una condizione in cui sono per esempio
simultaneamente entrambi rossi ed
entrambi blu attenzione che non appena
avete preparato questa condizione
essa vale indipendentemente dalla
distanza tra questi due oggetti
supponiamo quindi di lasciare a sulla
terra e di portare b sulla luna la
condizione d antan clemente significa
che se osservo a rosso anche bis al
rosso se osservo a blu anche b diventerà
blu ma ancora più sconvolgente se decido
di cambiare il colore di a in un colore
in cui nessuna delle due biglie
precedentemente era stata preparata per
esempio giallo ragazzi allora anche b
diventa giallo senza che nessuno abbia
fatto qualcosa sulla luna
questo è sconcertante perché significa
che io faccio qualcosa ora qui su un
oggetto e questo ha un effetto su un
altro oggetto molto lontano
il fenomeno del dl lentamente talmente
strano che disturbo lo stesso einstein
che infatti lo definì azione spettrale a
distanza tuttavia sia il principio di
sovrapposizione che lentamente sono
stati verificati da innumerevoli
esperimenti e la meccanica quantistica
rimane una delle teorie di maggior
successo in tutta la storia della
scienza queste stranissime bizzarre
proprietà quantistiche hanno poi delle
conseguenze inaspettate in campo
tecnologico con effetti potenzialmente
dirompenti possiamo infatti costruire un
beat quantistico
chiamiamolo qubit associando 0 al colore
blu è il valore 1 il colore rosso per
esempio quindi un compito è un oggetto
quantistico che può trovarsi
contemporaneamente nelle configurazioni
0 e 1 questo fa una grande differenza
con un beat digitale classico su cui si
basano i nostri computer e gli
smartphone
perché un beat classico può essere o
zero oppure 1 se volete farvi un'idea di
un qubit realistico potete pensare ad un
atomo che può stare in due possibili
livelli energetici cioè due possibili
orbite dell'elettrone attorno al nucleo
oppure per esempio pensate ad un fotone
che è il quanto di luce che può trovarsi
in due possibili polarizzazioni diverse
la polarizzazione essenzialmente la
direzione in cui punta il campo
elettromagnetico durante la propagazione
bene una volta che avrete il qubit
potete costruire un computer quantistico
il cui funzionamento si basa proprio su
un assemblaggio di molti qubit facciamo
n le potenzialità in termini di calcolo
di questo computer quantistico rispetto
ad un computer ordinario sono
potenzialmente enormi per capirlo basta
fare questo ragionamento tutte le
combinazioni possibili in cui possono
trovarsi i qubit yenne qubit sono due
elevato n
dovete fare 2 x 2 x 2 ripetuto nei volte
per intenderci se avete due qubit le
combinazioni possibili sono 4000 110 è 1
a questo punto il computer quantistico
grazie al principio di sovrapposizione
per sfruttare per elaborare
l'informazione contemporaneamente tutte
le due elevata n combinazioni degli n
qubit un computer ordinario questo non
può farlo perché ogni volta utilizzare
soltanto una delle possibili
configurazioni dei plastici capite che
si tratta in linea di principio di un
vantaggio di 2 elevata n
rispetto a uno a questo punto voi potete
collegare tanti computer quantistici per
creare una rete quantistica un quantum
network e in questo modo trasferire
l'informazione ed elaborarla sfruttando
proprio le potenzialità e le proprietà
dei cubi
bene che cosa ci possiamo fare bene per
esempio possiamo fare il teletrasporto
attenzione può portare trasporto
quantistico si intende il trasferimento
di informazione cioè delle proprietà
fisiche di un qubit e non di materia non
c'è nulla che viene smaterializzato
smontato da una parte e ricreato da
un'altra
inoltre non andiamo mai ad osservare o a
misurare le proprietà fisiche del qubit
che si vuole trasmettere per non
comprometterlo
inoltre e questo significa se ci pensate
è come se noi volessimo comunicare l'ora
che segna il nostro orologio senza mai
guardare l'orologio questo tipo di
teletrasporto si può fare se abbiamo due
qb chiamiamoli a e b 1 per esempio in un
osservatorio sul pianeta terra è un
altro per esempio nella stazione
spaziale internazionale
a patto che questi due qb ci sono nella
condizione d antan clemente che vi ho
descritto prima di interaction a questo
punto se voi avete un terzo qubit c e
volete trasferire le sue proprietà
fisiche da esso abi che il qubit che sta
sulla stazione spaziale
potete farlo facendo delle opportune
operazioni locali
nell'osservatorio e nella stazione
spaziale l'effetto finale
e che il qubit b è diventato blu come lo
era c cioè assunto esattamente le stesse
proprietà di ci siamo contenti a questo
punto bisogna rendersi conto che poter
fare il teletrasporto è essenziale per
costruire delle efficienti reti
quantistiche e considerate pure che sono
stati fatti moltissimi esperimenti di
teletrasporto tra un laboratorio di un
altro utilizzando i fotoni quanti di
luce e recentemente un team di
ricercatori cinesi ha addirittura
realizzato il teletrasporto tra un
laboratorio sul pianeta terra è un
satellite in orbita un altro aspetto
interessante è la fattorizzazione i
numeri primi se voi prendete un numero
molto grande per esempio composto da 300
cifre il più potente supercalcolatore
esistente per ora sulla terra
impiegherebbe qualcosa come 600 mila
anni per scomporlo infatti i primi un
computer quantistico ideale tramite
un'opportuna algoritmo ci metterebbe un
secondo
attenzione però che questo clamoroso
vantaggio in termini di velocità di
calcolo andrebbe a compromettere i
sistemi di sicurezza delle nostre carte
di credito password che sono basati
essenzialmente proprio sulla difficoltà
di scomporre un grande numero in fattori
premi tuttavia possiamo andare ad
intervenire con la crittografia
quantistica che permette di trasferire
informazioni e dati in totale sicurezza
a prova di spia tra un mittente un
ricevente infatti qualunque intervento
della spia all'interno della
comunicazione inevitabilmente andrebbe a
modificare le proprietà fisiche dei cubi
trasferiti e queste modifiche verrebbero
immediatamente rilevate dal ricevente
che a quel punto può decidere di
interrompere la comunicazione per
riprenderla in seguito anche in questo
caso sono stati fatti svariati
esperimenti in laboratorio che
realizzano la crittografia quantistica
informazione sicura tramite fotoni
ancora una volta quanti di luce e ci
sono addirittura delle compagnie che
iniziano a commercializzare dispositivi
che realizzano la crittografia
quantistica
ma adesso
la domanda interessante da fare è ma
quanto siamo effettivamente distanti
dall avere un computer quantistico
pratico efficiente nelle nostre mani
vi posso dire subito che i più grandi
colossi dell'informatica come ibm google
in collaborazione con la nasa la matteo
soft intel per esempio stanno investendo
enormi risorse in questa direzione
tutte queste compagnie hanno già dei
prototipi di computer quantistici con un
piccolo numero di qubit tipicamente
alcune decine di qubit è presente ibm ha
messo a disposizione online open source
il proprio prototipo di computer
quantistico essenzialmente per finalità
accademiche
ovviamente lo scopo finale ultimo è
quello di costruire un computer
quantistico con molti qubit per
sfruttarne tutte le sue enormi
potenzialità di calcolo in campi per
esempio come l'intelligenza artificiale
oppure la simulazione di sistemi molto
complessi per poter comprendere e
prevedere sempre meglio il loro
comportamento con implicazioni molto
importanti e clamorose per esempio anche
in campo medico per la progettazione di
farmaci
capite bene che queste grandi
potenzialità hanno suscitato un
grandissimo interesse da parte della
della opinione pubblica e anche dei
governi verso la meccanica quantistica e
il suo impatto tecnologico e questo è
dimostrato da un sacco di notizie ormai
che circolano in giro su questi
argomenti in tutti i canali di
comunicazione di massa ma anche per
quanto va degli investimenti che vengono
fatti in questo senso
per darvi un'idea di come la parola
quanto sia diventata di moda adesso mi
piace mostrarvi questa fotografia che ho
scattato la facciata di un edificio di
un bellissimo grattacielo nel quartiere
palermo di buenos aires e questo
cartellino si chiama proprio contro un
palermo che mi ha divertito moltissimo e
adesso però devo dirvi anche una cosa
importante i prototipi di computer
quantistico che abbiamo finora non
riescono ancora a manifestare davvero i
grandi vantaggi rispetto al computer e
ordinari rimangono infatti importanti
problemi platt pratici risolvere
innanzitutto la scalabilità nel senso
che molto molto difficile costruire dei
computer
quantistici molto efficienti con un
numero sempre piu grandi cubi
e poi c'è il problema della correzione
degli inevitabili errori che avvengono
durante i processi di calcolo e che
richiedono ulteriori cubiti di controllo
che vanno a complicare ulteriormente il
sistema
e poi c'è il problema del rumore dovuto
alla inevitabile interazione dei qubit
con l'ambiente circostante e che tende a
distruggere in tempi brevissimi le
proprietà quantistiche come la
sovrapposizione lentamente che invece
vogliamo mantenere il più a lungo
possibile per sfruttarle per i nostri
scopi la comunità scientifica sta
facendo sforzi enormi per cercare di
risolvere questi problemi però possiamo
serenamente dirci che passerà ancora del
tempo prima di vedere una diffusione su
larga scala dei computer quantistici
voglio adesso citare richard feynman uno
dei più grandi fisici del novecento che
diceva ho imparato presto la differenza
tra conoscere il nome di qualcosa e
conoscere qualcosa
questa frase mi piace un sacco perché
innanzitutto sintetizza un polo essenza
del fare ricerca perché fa ricerca
essenzialmente significa cercare di
approfondire di conoscere sempre di più
come si comportano le cose che ci
circondano non limitandosi semplicemente
al nome di queste cose e in più questa
bella frase mi permette di fare questa
riflessione finale
viviamo in un periodo storico in cui si
sta diffondendo una certa cultura anti
scientifica si dà credito ad assurde
teorie del complotto
basti pensare che c'è tutta una comunità
di persone è convinta che la terra sia
piatta e così quando basta per
dimostrare il contrario mettersi sul
molo di un porto ed osservare una nave
scomparire all'orizzonte la nave
scompare non perché la vista non ci
aiuta possiamo prendere un telescopio un
cannocchiale un vino pro non la vedremo
comunque scompare proprio che è
scomparso sotto l'orizzonte andata sotto
l'orizzonte per la curvatura terrestre
e potremmo continuare con le altre
assurde tesi del complotto sul fatto che
non ci sia mai stato lo sbarco sulla
luna nonostante le svariate missioni
apollo che sono
assolutamente ben documentate oppure le
fantomatiche scie chimiche vuoi discorsi
sui vaccini e allora permettetemi di
concludere con questo messaggio
fidatevi per favore degli scienziati che
dedicano la loro vita a cercare di
capire come veramente funzionano le cose
lo fanno con rigore e metodo scientifico
questo non è un atto di debolezza ma un
atto di grande intelligenza
grazie
[Applauso]